if you play any esports titles smurfing
is just something you have to deal with
gg go next but valve recently banned
smurfing from dota 2
entirely so today we're going to take a
look at what that means
not only for dota 2 but for other games
like valorant as well
[Music]
a smurf ruining your game might be
unexpected but you know what isn't
me asking you to absolutely destroy that
subscribe button and ring that
notification bell if you haven't already
we're trying to get our youtube mmr to 2
million and we're hoping you can help
carrie a little bit
plus if you do then you'll know the
moment we have a new story for you
gg okay so if you're unfamiliar with
smurfing just
bear with me like a lee sin in
challenger cueing into a silver game i
promise
i'll make this quick the basic
explanation is that it's a way for
skilled players to
circumvent their rank and play against
players they'd never normally
face normally that means a second
account
and in a free to play game it's easy
enough to get one
but why smurf at all a lot of people who
smurf say that they do it to play ranked
with friends
who otherwise wouldn't be able to queue
together a common response is just
okay so don't play ranked then but for
those same
people making the number go up is
important and in the streaming world
taking an account from bronze to the
highest level is pretty common
often times it's done with some kind of
special restriction in place like
only playing one hero or only playing a
certain role
all in the pursuit of that sweet sweet
content
just take tf blade for example who
decided he was gonna go from bronze to
challenger on every
league server on the planet which is
possibly the most
ambitious smurfing challenge ever we did
a whole video about this crazy adventure
a while back
if you want more info on the origins of
smurfing we did a video back
in 2018 which i also hosted
that goes a little bit more in depth and
i enjoy making up names and playing
people at war too
we make them think we really suck and
then beat them up we have lots of fun
playing as smurfs we talking smokes
we smurf some ass and water i guess that
is totally childish but
it sure is fun yeah so the videos were
a little different back then anyway from
a skill perspective
people who are smurfing don't belong in
the games that they're in
then on march 24th valves straight up
banned smurfs from dota 2.
like the notoriously hands-off valve
just decided to tackle one of the
biggest
problems plaguing games it's honestly
pretty shocking
they've actually been tracking smurf
accounts for a while now
and like many games they try to put
those accounts in games against each
other
but now if you smurf in dota 2 your
account will simply be banned
starting today smurfing will be a
bannable offense we will primarily focus
on new accounts created
after today for which we have high
confidence in their smurfing and game
ruining behavior
furthermore if you're found to be
selling accounts boosting or engaged in
similar game ruining behaviors
your primary account may also be subject
to a ban
yes your primary account won't be banned
unless you're selling accounts or
boosting seemingly this change is part
of a bigger patch that does a lot to
make the game friendlier to new players
it just makes sense given that valve
missed the international 2020
and dota generally is just pretty
difficult for new players
oh yeah they released a dota 2 anime as
well
that's pretty cool i guess insert wow
anyway valve's decision is a huge step
against smurfing
it's a commitment to fairness of course
but
it's also a big undertaking that
developers can't commit to lightly
to be clear valve's new hardline
approach towards smurfing isn't the norm
in many games including league of
legends smurfing is just
accepted as an evil of a matchmaking
system that tries to pit opponents
against each other
in a fair way sure there are measures in
place to detect
and then move smurfs out of mmr brackets
they don't belong in
but generally speaking smurfing itself
is not directly penalized
[Music]
don't worry about it
in clash league's tournament system
there are rules against it and riot says
that they'll ban smurfs that engage in
game ruining behavior but for the most
part
it's something that you just have to
deal with speaking of riot it seems like
they're taking their 12
years of dealing with smurfing in league
and applying what they've learned
to valorant since its early days riot
has developed valorent with smurfing in
mind
back in patch 1.6 they made it so that
forfeiting
unraided matches doesn't count towards
ranked
this forced players on a smurf account
to actually
play the 20 unranked matches in order to
unlock competitive
before this change smurf players got
around this by killing themselves at the
beginning of a round
which caused players to forfeit games
and tricked valorant's system into
checkmarking those games as
played then in october 2020 during a
developer q a
riot had this to say about smurfing
while it's hard to stop smurfing
entirely in a free-to-play game
we are taking action to combat it right
now we have a behind the scenes system
for unranked as well as one that applies
to iron through diamond ranked players
the latter tracks an individual's
performance and notices when a player
makes a highly disproportionate
impact in a game we then quickly boost
them to harder matches and higher ranks
in competitive
then in november with patch 1.14 riot
made it so that ranked valorem play
required 10
wins and not 10 games played which
should hopefully cut down on people just
afking in matches so they can begin to
smurf
then recently in early march riot
released patch 2.04 and noted that they
were continuing to balance ranked
so that as you rank up quote you'll find
a tighter disparity
to ensure we continue to maintain
balanced matches
and protect the competitive integrity of
the higher ranks
according to riot these small changes
will combat smurfing by reducing the
incentive to make a new account
to play with lower ranked friends all of
this is to say that riot seems to be
doing everything they can
to combat smurfing and valorent sort of
outright
banning smurfing in the game but who
knows maybe we'll see a smurf-sized bomb
dropped on the game at a later date
here's hiko giving his thoughts about
smurfing invalorant as well as
talking about the problem in general
smurfing ruins two separate things right
smurfing ruins the game you're in so
not only the person that you're playing
with you're ruining that guy that guy or
girl's account
by uh you know boosting the rank
and and getting them wins they shouldn't
get and they're not getting it on their
own they're not getting better
you're also boosting all the people on
your team because you're getting them a
free win if you're doing like 50 kills
um but also you're ruining the game
for the person that you're surfing with
the person you're boosting
that person is they're ruining the game
for everyone on their team in the future
when they end up solo queuing
and they're a mortal one but they should
be silver
so smurfing literally only
hurts in the immediate future and in the
long-term future
and why do people smurf in valorem
well one reason might be that like
league valorent has this culture of
prestige
about having multiple high level
accounts
like doink machine 97 also known as
poise
who plays for cloud9 blue side note
great name you've earned a fan for life
obviously when you get to the top you're
not really smurfing anymore
but that account had to start somewhere
and if my experience is any indication
it started stomping gold
players with reina weirdly in
counter-strike things can be a little
different
sure there are people who smurf but if
you want to play
face it and if you're a good cs player
you probably do
you're just not allowed to smurf all of
this leads me to this point
is this the first move of many could
other games implement measures like
dota did to keep players happy at first
glance it seems
unlikely for one doing this takes
resources and if you build an
automated system to detect smurfs
sometimes it's going to get things wrong
secondly the most vocal advocates for
changes to games
tend to be players at the highest
echelon of play
pro players and content creators there
oh these guys are sniping hockey 44.7
meters my 12 o'clock right now wait i
could have won
straight north there are two straight
there
[Music]
could have won dude okay most content
creators
tend to be playing at a higher level
smurfing typically isn't an issue they
encounter so it's not something they're
likely to be complaining about
and they're the ones with the biggest
platforms to advocate for change to this
game
and there's another reason why smurf
accounts are unlikely to be banned in
other games
it's bad for business even if an account
is free to play
smurf players can still buy things for
those accounts
and if their incredible performance
makes the game fun for a couple of their
friends
and they end up spending money in the
game well that's even better
with all that said why ban smurfs well
the answer is that
playing against smurfs constantly is
demoralizing
and if people choose to stop playing
your game as a result
that's also bad for business as the
announcement points out dota 2
is already really volatile without the
massive skill gaps
unless you're the kind of player that
loves getting stomped by a smurfing
ricky
in which case stop it get some help
learning a game like dota 2 is a journey
you've got a long way to go
and players want that experience to be
like a satisfying hike or a challenging
climb
not a plane crash in the wilderness
but with all the emphasis on both
bringing in new players and making their
experiences positive
it sure seems like it's a priority for
dota 2's development team
so will other developers do it well i
hope so
it's still really hard to imagine most
of them
favor solutions that simply detect the
smurfs and then get them as far away as
possible from players that they
shouldn't be matched with
but i'm willing to bet that the other
big developers will be watching this
experiment closely
if banning smurfs can help players flock
to a complex game
like dota 2 imagine what it could do for
those other games
what do you think should we just suffer
through the smurfs or
is it time to hit them with the old ban
hammer eyes
let us know in the comments below like
i'm at like [ __ ] belly buster subs
trying to just get my order but it's the
sub
i mean that's a good point though if you
get shrunk down to smurf size and you
order a footlong sub
that's like probably two meals right
you're probably saving huge dollars on
food well that's the rest of your world
like you literally can't see over the
top of the sub
if you're sitting down next to it